hello everyone and welcome to the
biggest ideas in the universe I'm your
host Sean Carroll and this is the QA
video associated with idea number five I
believe it is called time somehow I
managed to go through the entire actual
video on time without mentioning the
most important fact about time which is
that I wrote a book about it this is
very important for authors to mention my
publisher be very mad at me if I didn't
let you know that from eternity to here
the quest for the ultimate theory of
time it's the first trade book I ever
wrote it discusses much of the things
we've already talked about in the last
video you know the eternalism versus
present ISM stuff a little bit about
relativity and time travel and is mostly
about entropy and the arrow of time and
some of the cosmological scenarios that
could lead to that as well as some of
the implications we're gonna mostly get
to relativity and entropy later in the
series so I know there's a lot of Q&A
questions about relativity general
relativity special relativity entropy
one way or the other
not that I'm ignoring those questions
but they will be addressed later on and
the book addresses them in great detail
so you might want to check that out
available wherever books are available I
mean what else are you doing you're
reading you're learning new things so if
you've discovered my videos or my books
more recently this was a 2010 book that
I'm still quite proud of and it's all
about time so moving into the questions
again I'm gonna be more inspired by the
questions and go through a little
literal order of them there was one sort
of set of questions about whether time
is real and what that really means and I
think that I just didn't do a very good
job of explaining what I was trying to
do in the first video what I talked
about whether time is real or not so
maybe just putting in slightly different
words will help the basic ideas come
through so is time real time real the
answer is yes but different people might
claim that the answer is no not because
they have a different notion of time but
because they have a different notion of
what the word real means again as I said
in the first video you know everyone
knows what it means when you say be at a
certain place at a p.m. that's a
completely useful in fact necessary
concept for getting through the
so time is absolutely real in that
operational pragmatic sense but there's
two other kind of distinguished
distinctions that you might want to draw
one is fundamental versus emergent and I
think this is what a lot of people have
in mind when they say the time is not
real they really mean is that it's not
fundamental so the analogy I always use
here is it's not an exact analogy for
this case but it gets the general idea
across you know if you think about a box
of gas okay this kind of thing the
physicists will often do know when my
pen is skipping so we know that a box of
gas is made of atoms molecules you know
little particles of gas rolling around
inside the box bumping into each other
so there's a way of talking about ooh
the box of gas that says it's made of
particles depending what the gas is
there if the atoms or molecules or
whatever but there's another way of
talking about the gas that says it's a
fluid gasses count as fluids so this
means it has you know a temperature a
pressure density and it's a smooth
continuous thing now we thought back in
the day before we knew about atoms that
gases just were fluids and this is the
most fundamental description you could
make of them we realized in the 1900s in
the 19th century sorry that in fact the
air around us is made of atoms and
molecules other gases are also made out
of atoms and molecules so they so that
the gas is not really smooth and
continuous like a fluid would be if you
get down to the microscopic level so we
know now that a more fundamental
description of the gas is in terms of
the particles as far as we know you can
completely describe the gas in terms of
the particles whereas you cannot
completely describe it as a fluid
there's certain questions you might want
to ask about the gas that can be
answered using the particle description
cannot be answered using the fluid
description nevertheless it would be
silly to
say that it was an illusion that the gas
is a fluid in fact we use the idea of
the gas being a fluid all the time we
talk about its temperature we talk about
the temperature the air outside the the
atmospheric pressure the velocity of the
air all these things that make perfect
sense in the fluid description but not
in the gas description that's okay this
is the more fundamental description in
terms of particles this is the more
emergent description because it comes
out only at this higher level of
abstraction there's a it's it's both
that you look at it sort of from above
you sort of squint and you you fuzz over
all the individual microscopic
idiosyncrasies of the particles or you
can say that in terms of the domain of
validity of this description the
particle description is valid in more
situations like if there's only one
particle in the box the particle
description is still perfectly good but
the gas description is not the emergent
description is generally true as an
approximation in some particular domain
of validity or domain of applicability
but that doesn't make any less real it's
perfectly okay to talk about the reality
of the fluid and I think the time is
exactly like that there's a lot of
people who will say well time is a way
of talking about the relations between
different parts of the universe in some
more fundamental timeless description
but that doesn't mean the time is
somehow an illusion it's just emergent
but it's still just as real as if it
were fundamental if you believe the
tables and chairs people and planets are
real then you should believe the time is
real but there's another notion another
sort of way of slicing this problem that
is a little bit different and rather
than saying fundamental versus emerging
we can talk about passive versus active
and this is a sort of slightly different
distinction that some people have in
mind when they say that time is real or
is not real what I mean by that is in
the block universe perspective that we
talked about in the last video you know
here's I'll draw the universe literally
as a block okay so this is space these
two dimensions this is time going up
this way so one moment
like the present might be a little slice
of the universe like this so this is now
to somebody of course to people in the
past or the future they will call their
moments now but that's as part of the
nomenclatural difficulty of dealing with
the block universe and in this picture
in this block universe picture time is
just a coordinate time doesn't make
anything happen anymore than space it
makes things happen time is just a way
of locating events in the universe that
event is in the future of what we have
labeled now in this particular picture
whereas there's a picture of time that
does not really fit well with the block
universe picture but one in which time
is either is or at least is associated
with bringing the universe into
existence so somehow time is the thing
that takes you now and moves you into
the future not sure exactly if anyone
would talk in exactly those terms but
this is the basic spirit behind what
they're saying and this is a distinction
that goes along with a different point
of view on the nature of the laws of
physics themselves it's not again it's
not exactly one to one you know for any
of the professional philosophers in the
audience
I apologize for glossing over a lot of
important details here but in spirit
this picture of the block universe goes
along with something called a human
perspective not human human as in David
Hume view of the laws of physics and
this other view doesn't have a person
really associated with them so it is
called anti-human and the difference is
that the human view simply says the laws
of physics are an encapsulation of all
the stuff that happens in the universe
so what is real in the human view what
is what is important what defines the
nature of reality is everything that
happens all the stuff that there is and
configuration of that stuff at every
moment in time at every location in
space or if someday we replace
space-time some more fundamental
structure then whatever the collection
of stuff is the collection of physical
happenings that is the universe and a
human would say the laws of physics are
just patterns obeyed by the actual stuff
it's the stuff that matters
the laws are just a convenient
description of the stuff whereas an
anti-human really thinks of the laws of
physics as creating the universe the
laws of physics have some extra oomph to
them over and above just being a
description and again since I'm more of
a human mostly myself so I'm not exactly
sure the most can that the most
convenient and effective way to put this
into words but they really think that
there is some reality to the becoming
you know very roughly and sort of hi to
Gary in terms this is being and this is
becoming okay again very innocent
looking words with many many thousands
of words of philosophy underlying them
if you want to talk about them in
different ways
i I'm not gonna talk about this
difference in great detail right here if
you're interested in the distinction you
can look at the podcast I did with Ned
Hall who's a chair of the philosophy
department at Harvard and we talked
about this human versus anti human view
of the laws of physics but you can see
how it relates to time if you're human
if you just think the laws of physics
are a description that is convenient for
us then time is just a label right is
where are you which event are we talking
about right now whereas if you're anti
human time really has a much more active
role it's bringing the universe into
existence so there are those who when
they say the phrase time is real I
consider time to be real what they mean
is that time is not just a coordinate
time has a more active role I think that
people like Lee Smolin fall into this
camp although he should speak for
himself that's my understanding of what
he's trying to say so when they say time
is real
they don't just mean time is either
fundamental or emergent but time is a
useful description they mean time is
doing something
active playing an important role in
bringing the universe about I think the
time is real but I also think that it's
passive I think the time is just a
coordinate just a label it's not
bringing anything into existence there's
no boom Finas to time is just a
convenient way of talking but it's still
real just like I think the space is real
in exactly the same way so that's just
some nomenclatural clarification if you
hear people saying oh unlike others I
think time is real maybe what they mean
is they think the time has an active
role to play okay
there's two more little nomenclatural
cleaning up jobs we have to do one is is
the block universe if you're if you're
an eternal list and you believe in the
block universe some people say well if
you live in the block universe then if
you believe in the block universe then
you think that the universe is static or
it is unchanging so how can sometimes
they say these final words out loud also
how can change ever happen isn't this in
conflict with our experience of the
world since we seem to be thinking about
the world as changing all the time and
this is you know I you know I tried to
explain this so I'll try to explain it
again I think maybe I'm just getting
something unclear myself here it's my
fault but the point is to a block
universe person here's the universe the
point of the block universe is that all
moments of time are equally real okay
it's not that reality is the three
dimensions of space at one moment of
time and reality used to be something
different and will be something
different in the future reality is the
whole four-dimensional shebang that's
what the block universe person believes
so it's easy to look at this picture and
say look there's nothing changing right
if I if I just erased this label there
then it just looks like a block so
nothing is can possibly be changing but
the point is if you believe this you
just have to be careful about what you
mean by the word change and static in
the block universe what you mean by
change is
what happened what is happening here is
different than what's happening here in
the block universe okay at some
different moment of time that's what
change means it means that not all these
slices are the same changes the
difference between one slice and another
it's not something that happens to the
four-dimensional universe as a whole so
again I think this is in some sense down
to our linguistic inadequacies because
the language was invented long before
these concepts were invented we think
and when you use the words like static
or unchanging you're assuming a certain
notion of time that is not quite
appropriate to this four dimensional
block universe in the four dimensional
block universe the differences that
we're talking about between one time in
another are relational compared to one
earlier time there's a difference at
some later time okay between those two
times things changed the universe the
the state of reality at any one of those
moments is not the same as the state of
reality at a different moment that's
what it means to be not static that's
what it means to be changing the whole
thing isn't changing the whole thing
encompasses change the four-dimensional
world describes change but it is not
itself changing I hope that made some
sense that's the point so you don't need
to say if you're blocking universe
person that there's no such thing as
change the universe is static or
anything like that
finally there's the question along
related vein
you know don't we observe the past so
this is an argument the other way around
this is an argument you know isn't the
block universe
obviously right because I can look out
into the sky at stars and galaxies and
relativity teaches me that the light
from those stars and galaxies travels at
1 light year per year it took a long
time for it to get to us so what we see
when we look outside is the state of the
universe of these stars and galaxies in
the past so a pro block universe person
might say isn't it obvious that the past
is just as real as the present because I
am observing it when I go outside
sadly no even though I believe in the
block universe this argument doesn't
quite convince me of anything and the
reason is it if you're really strictly a
hundred percent careful when you go
outside and you look at the sky and you
see stars etc you're not looking at the
past what you're seeing is not the past
what you're seeing is light hitting your
eye right now at that moment but there's
an additional step where you say well
because the light hit my eye at this
moment I infer a certain thing about the
past namely there was a star or galaxy
shining in a particular way that created
that light that got to me but that's in
your mind right you are creating a
connection between the thing you see
right now and the conditions of the
universe in the past it's not quite
right to say that you're actually
observing the past you're inferring
something about the past from your
present observations okay now let me get
to a couple of more substantive
questions less about language and
nomenclature and so forth basically one
question that sort of gets asked in
different ways about the reversibility
of the universe or in similar words the
time symmetry so I made a big point in
the first video of saying that if you
reverse everything in the universe so if
you were at the microscopic level
looking at something that was not big
and had entropy and dissipation and
everything but just had a small number
of moving parts you could make a movie
of it you could play it backwards it
would look the same this is a feature of
the fundamental laws of physics as we
understand them
that they can be they can go either way
in time you can take the universe right
now if you're Laplace is demon you can
predict both the future but also the
past because of this reversibility
feature so people try to come up with a
couple of examples where they say well
this doesn't look reversible to me and
let me trip sort of explain what's going
on so one is gravity the idea here is
that gravity only goes one way right
gravity only pulls us
together that's what gravity does isn't
this someone might say an example of
irreversibility things only fall down
apples fall from trees apples do not
spontaneously leap up into trees because
gravity is always pulling them down so
this is a little bit of a mix-up between
the fundamental laws of physics and the
macroscopic ones in the case of the
Apple but there's also something even at
the fundamental level going on you have
to really understand what is meant by
reversibility so let's say that here's
the ground and here's a person and this
person throws a ball up in the air okay
so the ball goes up in the air and it
will fly in a certain trajectory it goes
up and it comes down the point of the
reversibility of gravity is that if you
took the ball right here which now has a
velocity pointing toward the ground if
you ran time backward and reversed that
velocity it would go exactly backward
let's see if I can do this it would go
exactly backward on exactly the same
trajectory and get to exactly the same
point so anything that is a solution to
Newton's equations for gravity and for
motion forward in time is also a
solution backward in time so the fact
that gravity pulls things together
that's true but when you reverse you
reverse not only the fact that the ball
is over here and going down but you
reverse its velocity also you say you
move it in the other direction and
there's different ways of thinking about
this one way the simplest most naive way
is just to say look the velocity is the
derivative of the rate of change of the
position with respect to time so if you
reverse time you reverse the velocity
right velocity equals DX DP so when T
goes to minus T that implies that the
velocity goes to minus the velocity
there you go okay so that's the aspect
of reversibility we have so general
relativity Newtonian gravity Newtonian
mechanics all of these things are 100%
reversible in that sense what we really
mean by reversibility is you can start
with a situation at one moment in time
and go either forward or backward
without losing information so there's
another example people asked about which
is what about radioactive decay this is
a may be looking forward a little bit
but that's okay we can talk about it so
there's a rule that if you have a
nucleus with a lot of particles in it
more particles then I'm gonna draw it
here but you have some nucleus and over
time the nucleus can decay and let's see
if I can redraw this it's more like a
bunch of grapes doesn't it so get rid of
that and let's say that one of these
particles spits out you know an electron
or a photon or something like that or
there's more dramatic ways that can
decay than splitting too but the point
is in the rules that we are taught you
cannot predict exactly when the nucleus
is going to decay you were given a
probability per unit time that the
nucleus is going to decay so in some
sense it cannot be run backwards right
like if you have a nucleus if you have
the nucleus that is already decayed and
you look at that you don't know when it
decayed in the past you can't sort of
run the movie backwards so I'm gonna
kind of punt this example a little bit
because of course this involves quantum
mechanics and quantum mechanics is not
classical mechanics and quantum
mechanics is a much subtler story to be
told about reversibility I mean the
reason why I'm saying that is because we
don't know whether quantum mechanics is
reversible or not at the fundamental
level you may have heard that there are
controversies about what quantum
mechanics actually is what the real
formulation of it is what the
fundamental ontology of it is and
different versions of quantum mechanics
have different perspectives on
reversibility some of them are
reversible some of them are not the
many-worlds interpretation has this
in-between stance where the wave
function of the universe as a whole
evolves in a completely reversible way
but any one branch does not look
reversible because we see less and less
of the wavefunction the universe as time
goes on so that's how you finesse that
in many worlds but all I'm gonna say
right now is radioactive decay doesn't
count for any of the talking I was doing
about reversibility because it's not
part of classical mechanics oh and then
the final one very similar here
what about violation of T symmetry in
particle physics you may have heard of
this
so in particle physics field theory
really quantum field theory which again
we'll talk more about later on but
there's three discrete symmetries to
play a crucially important role in
particle physics there is C which is
charge conjugation which is basically
you the word came about that the label
charge conjugation came about because
you reverse the sign of the charges of
elementary particles like an electron
with a negative charge under the C
transformation becomes a positron with a
positive charge but really what it means
is that the electric charge just goes
along for the ride really it's a matter
antimatter asymmetry you swap particles
for anti particles it's a discrete
symmetry because you're not smoothly
rotating between an electron and a
positron you're discretely just
switching electron goes to positron and
it has this property that if you do it
twice you come back to where you started
electron under charge conjugation goes
to positron positron and the charge
conjugation goes to electron likewise
there is a symmetry called P for parody
which is basically mirror reversal right
you know that when you look at something
in the mirror it looks like left to
right has been switched so roughly
speaking if you have axes X Y Z these
are axes in space parody takes these and
flips their orientations
one way to draw it would be X Y Z so you
go from what's called a right-handed
coordinate system to a left handed
coordinate system it's mirror symmetry
in that sense be careful because in
string theory there's an entirely
different symmetry called mirror
symmetry that's nothing do with parity
sorry about that
and finally there's T which is time
reversal and that literally just
reverses the direction of time as you
know so it turns out that you might
think these are all very good symmetries
in nature if you changed all the matter
in the universe for antimatter and
vice-versa you might think it's
completely the same the universe that
you're in turns out not to be true every
single one of these three symmetries
charge parity and time reversal
invariance are not completely satisfied
by the real world in actual particle
physics experiments you can there are
things you can do like the decay of a
neutron where if you held them up to a
mirror okay the rate at which that
situation would happen is different than
the rate of which the situation
originally happens so there's a
violation of parity symmetry likewise
time reversal and charge conjugation are
both individually violated so you might
worry you might say well wait a minute
you've been saying that the universe is
time reversal invariant and now you're
telling me it's not now of course what I
really been saying is the classical
mechanics is time reversal invariant and
this is modern quantum particle physics
but that's not the little loophole I'm
going to use in this particular example
the loophole I'm going to use here is
that you need to be careful about what
do you mean by time reversal okay so
let's think about what is actually meant
by time reversal remember we did the
example I just did the example of the
ball when I ignore the person here but
the ball that's thrown up in some
trajectory goes in a parabola falls down
here and has a momentum or a velocity
was called momentum when it first leaves
and then down here it's momentum is more
or less in the opposite direction I can
probably do a better job of drawing it
like that okay
so this is at time t2 this is at time
t1 okay let me do a little bit better
there - this is for posterity should do
the job so when you do the time reversal
if you start with X at time t1 the
position and P at time t1 the momentum
you don't just flip it
I shouldn't say t1 it should have said
t0 T - there so what I mean is the time
that at the end if I it doesn't matter
it can do time reversal invariance
whenever I want but I'm examining the
situation when the ball is just about to
hit I want to rewind the clock right so
I'm doing my time reversal reflection as
it were my time reversal transformation
at the moment just before the ball hits
the floor which I called t2 okay so to
do the time reversal to ask the question
what does it mean to run the clock
backwards what do I do to X and P to the
position and the momentum well X stays
the same X goes to X this is time
reversal invariance so it goes to
exactly what it was X at time t2 but I
reverse the momentum it becomes minus P
at t2 and you say well that makes sense
because back up here I said time goes to
minus T therefore velocity goes to minus
velocity momentum is just well momentum
is just mass times velocity
that's the Newtonian way of thinking in
the Hamiltonian way of thinking remember
we talked about the idea that position
momentum are fundamental right that you
don't think about momentum as being
defined as mass times velocity it works
out to be that but that's not the
definition momentum is a fundamental
thing all by itself and that's the point
in order to say to make the statement
the laws of physics are invariant under
time reversal you need to be very very
specific about what it means to reverse
the direction of time you don't just run
the clock backwards you change the
fundamental variables that you're
evolving at the same time when you go to
electricity and magnetism for example
the magnetic field reverses its
direction when do a time reversal
invariance so they're the answer to the
time reversibility of fundamental
physics given that T is violated is that
think about real time reversal as a
combination of C P and T that is to say
you take the system you have you hold it
up in a mirror you reverse the direction
of time and you change particles with
anti particles okay this symmetry which
I can invent which involves reversing
the direction of time is as far as we
know a perfectly obeyed symmetry of
nature there's no violation of it so the
violations that we observe of T and P
and C individually cancel out when you
do all of them at once in fact this is a
theorem under certain reasonable
assumptions quantum field theory with
the symmetries of special relativity etc
CPT is always going to be true you can
violate it by violating those
assumptions but experimentally as far as
nature is concerned CPT seems to be a
perfectly good symmetry and that's all
we need to say the laws of physics as
far as we know seem to be reversible at
the fundamental level
just don't use T naively as your time
reversal operation use CPT and that
makes perfect sense to us okay now
having said all that that was all the
actual questions but I want to talk a
little bit about the there's a set of
issues here that get mixed together that
all relate to each other concerning time
travel ooh that was a bad job writing
there travel determinism
and freewill I'm not going to give the
once-and-for-all
correct story of freewill here in this
video but we can talk about a little bit
because it's relevant to the question of
time and time travel so by time travel I
mean in particular travel into the past
right let me just say this in words
because it goes by very quickly of
course you can travel in time to the
future right I did that yesterday and I
travelled 24 hours into the future and
Here I am now that's sort of a trivial
old joke that people use I've used it
myself many times what you mean by time
travel is generally travel into the past
so is time travel into the past possible
if Isaac Newton had been correct right
if space and time were absolute which is
what we've been talking about so far you
have time here space here then no travel
into the past is just not possible you
just get older the rule is you can only
age into the future the same thing is
true in special relativity Einstein's
1905 theory of you know speed of light
being the maximum and things like that
but in general relativity gr we're gonna
get the GR later but in general
relativity space-time is curved okay
which means that you can curve so much
that you can actually imagine going back
to the past and the simplest way to do
this is through a wormhole okay so I'm
not gonna draw a spacetime diagram this
is just a space space diagram here but
here's a wormhole you've heard about
these things in science fiction movies
etc a wormhole is a situation where you
can hop in one side go through it and
come out the other side so it is in
principle a shortcut through space
because even though I drew it this way
so it looks like it takes longer through
the wormhole the distance from one end
of the wormhole to the other might be
very very short so I can't draw it that
way on this particular piece of paper
sometimes you see it drawn like this so
imagine that you fold over your
2-dimensional illustration of space to
look like this
and then the wormhole is just sort of
connecting one side of this to the other
like that so then it really does look
like a shortcut well the thing is if you
can travel faster than the speed of
light you can go backward in time this
is something we'll talk about soon in a
different video and so that's what a
wormhole lets you do it lets you travel
apparently faster than the speed of
light by taking a shortcut
so what Kip Thorne and others realized
is that if you have a wormhole and you
can take a shortcut through space you
can also take a shortcut through time in
fact you can synchronize one end of the
wormhole and the other at different
moments of time so you as far as the
universe is concerned hop in the
wormhole at one moment of time and you
can get spit out in the far future or
the far past so in principle this is a
spacetime diagram in principle I don't
think this can actually happen in the
real world but here's a general
relativity space-time diagram time-space
but now there's a wormhole and this
remember this loop that was not very
good this is a spacetime diagram so the
wormhole is going to look like two
little circles at any one moment in time
two little spheres one in which you go
in and one of which you go out and the
rule is if you hop in the wormhole at
this moment I just made up this rule but
it's okay the idea is I'm allowed to
make it up I pop out over here at a much
earlier time and then I could imagine
traveling backward they were traveling
to the left and visiting myself before I
hopped in so that's a real time machine
that's really going backward in time
clearly I'm skipping steps and leaving
out some niceties but this is the basic
general idea so in general relativity
where you can curve space-time is it is
at least possible to imagine travelling
backward in time visiting yourself in
the past this brings up logical
paradoxes right the grandfather paradox
what if you went and killed your
grandparents before they met and a
to your parents or your father your
mother and then where would you come
from or what if you just changed history
right if what if you travel back and
kill baby Hitler baby Hitler is usually
the person that gets chosen for being
killed wouldn't that leave you in a
completely different universe and this
gives rise to paradoxes and some weird
movies and stuff like this so I'm going
to give you the two simplest ways out of
these paradoxes the first simple way out
is time travel is not possible so we
don't actually know whether or not in
general relativity situations like this
with the wormhole sending you backward
in time are actually feasible or
actually possible to imagine doing we
can we can imagine them but we can't
prove one way or the other is whether
they are doable in the real world it
seems from a bunch of different
investigations that if you tried to make
a time machine this way what you would
actually end up making is a big black
hole that would just suck you in and
never let you leave we don't know of any
robust provable way to send yourself
backward in time so that's the cheap way
out the next best way out is whatever
happened happened this might be familiar
to those of you who are fans of lost of
the TV show they went the time travel
route in later seasons as many TV shows
do but they actually did a pretty good
job of it you could travel backward in
time in the world of loss to the TV show
but the point is that when you go into
the past from the point of view of your
present self that past already happened
so the rule was you could go into the
past but not change the past in any way
because it already happened whatever
happened happened if you go into the
past and do something that thing you did
was always true in your personal past
okay Louis it's not the first TV show or
movie or story to have this rule in it
but they have this fun motto whatever
happened happened you can buy t-shirts
with this motto on it okay and what that
means is like let's say you go back in
time and you you somehow find a time
machine
normal or something like that and you
try to kill baby Hitler well under this
theory of time travel you will fail I
can't tell you why you will fail alright
I can't tell you what stops you but I
know you will fail because Hitler did
not die when he was a baby Hitler really
existed this is a way to get out of the
apparent paradoxes of time travel in
classical physics now parenthetically
there's also the possibility of quantum
mechanics right and if you believe in
many worlds you might think I could go
to a different branch of the
wavefunction David Deutsch and others
have talked about this possibility but
to be honest I do not think that it is
really understood how that would work
but certainly you can hand wave your way
in to saying well you're in a different
parallel reality so the rules are
different not talking about that right
now what we're doing is imagining the
rules under which time travel could be
valid in a classical universe and the
answer is if and only if whatever
happened happened
we know that Hitler wasn't killed as a
baby so if you can go back into the past
whatever happens to you does not include
you killing baby Hitler
okay now this bugs us this is why it's a
paradox you mean you say well but I have
my time machine I go back there there's
baby Hitler you know no one's guarding
him no one knows he deserves to be
guarded I have a gun what's to stop me
from doing my job and killing baby
Hitler and the answer is we don't know
but you will be stopped
so this bugs us because it seems to be a
conflict between the past versus our
free will right we think we have the
ability to go and choose to kill baby
Hitler but we also know the past is
fixed the past already happened and baby
Hitler did not die so this seems to be a
conflict whereas when you imagine going
into the future
this is seems to be less of a conflict
because we don't know what happened in
the future okay so this is where the
determinism parts of this oops what did
I do here yeah
this is where the determinism parts of
this story come into play
if you believe in Laplace is demon the
past and future are equally fixed okay
so time travel because it mixes up your
personal future once you hop into the
time machine with the past of the
universe because it's already in the
past that gives us a sort of a bad
feeling about our freewill because our
ability to make choices seems to
conflict with the fact that the past is
fixed but really if you're more careful
about it the same thing is true about
the future everything is deterministic
if you believe in Laplace's daemon again
if you if classical physics were true
which it's not etc so you didn't have
any free will in that sense either the
difference is only that you don't know
what the future will actually bring and
therefore you feel like you have free
will toward the future now I'm not going
to give the whole freewill speech here
as promised but there are those of us
called compatible lists who think this
fact that we don't know what's going to
happen in the future
and we never will know right it's not
like well we don't know yet but we'll
find out it will never have the ability
to predict the future with perfect
accuracy or even anything close to
perfect accuracy that means it is
perfectly sensible to talk about making
choices and having the ability to do one
thing versus another because we just
don't know it might be back baked into
the laws of physics and the state of the
universe today but if you don't know it
that has absolutely zero impact on how
you get through the day nobody literally
goes around going well I'm not gonna
choose what to do today miss could let
the laws of physics work their magic
okay when you walk into a restaurant the
old Drogo's and the wait staff comes up
and says what would you like for dinner
you don't say just give me what the
universe has determined I'm going to
have okay you make a choice and it's
that effective making the choices back
to the emergent versus fundamental
freewill is not fundamental it's not
built into the laws of physics at the
microscopic level but the macroscopic
level when we describe human beings it's
absolutely crucial to talk about human
beings as making choices so again I'm
not going to give the full defense of
that compared
this point of view of what I want to let
you know that it's there if you're
wondering how we can possibly reconcile
our ability to make choices with a
deterministic laplacian universe and let
me give you one final fun example about
this exact puzzle this is called this is
an example called new Newcomb's paradox
some of you will be very familiar with
this some of you will or in for a treat
if you're not already familiar with this
so Newcomb's paradox will even Newcombe
suggested the following idea you are
shown two boxes okay
box 1 box 2 are put on a table in front
of you and this box is transparent and
this box is opaque is one of those
philosophy thought experiments where
you're offered a choice and you're asked
what you want to do so in the
transparent box you see there's $1,000
there it is it's right there yours for
the taking in the opaque box you are
told that there's either a million
dollars or zero dollars you're not told
which one okay and you know you you're
you're supported at this point if you're
not familiar with the puzzle you're
guessing what's gonna happen you're
asked do you want the thousand dollar
box or do you want the opaque box with
either zero or a million no that is not
what you're what you're asked what are
your acts asked well you're given the
choices you can choose call this box a
box B so your choices you can choose to
take either only box hang get the
thousand dollars you can choose either
box B if you want that you want to take
the risk right or you can choose both I
bet you weren't anticipating that where
are you you could just take both boxes
right at this point you're saying we'll
wait a minute I will choose to take both
boxes because I know there's a thousand
dollars in box a
whatever is in box would be I don't know
but if I choose to take it I'll get it
if it's zero at zero if it's a millions
million I might as well choose right the
boxes are already there it's not that
anyone's going to fiddle with the boxes
after you make your choices
okay the boxes are there they're sitting
in front of you so there's clearly one
perspective which says no matter what I
should just take two boxes the decision
theory argument is there's an expected
value of taking one box thousand dollars
these expected value taking both boxes
$1,000 plus some fraction times a
million dollars okay the fraction of
likelihood that the million dollars is
actually there here's the complication
you knew there's a complication coming
right
the complication is there is a an Oracle
and withdraw the Oracle has a looming
red blob okay there you go that's the
Oracle well actually the work is called
the predictor I think in that so the
predictor is some sum being that has
access to what is going to happen in the
future okay or at least knowledge you
can think of the predictor as maybe
Laplace is demon if you want to be
mechanistic about it or you can think of
the predictor as something that has
recognition something it has the ability
to actually look at the future and see
what will happen and the predictor says
the following so let me write this in
red I'll make a little smaller here the
predictor tells you something before you
make your choice
the predictor says if
if you choose just to take bucks B to
leave a there okay then box Pete will
have 1 million dollars in it whereas if
you choose both B is empty
this is Newcomb's paradox okay so the
predictor is the spanner in the works
the predictor is the thing that makes it
a non-trivial problem the predictor
which we believe or have good reason to
believe
super duper really good reason to
believe is a hundred percent accurate
the predictor is predicting the future
and the predictor says if you choose
both boxes you're gonna get a thousand
dollars if you choose only box B you
will get a million dollars so this is a
paradox this is the tension on the one
hand the money is already there okay the
there's either a million dollars in box
B or there's not there's a very sensible
logical set of statements that says I
can only make more money by taking both
boxes than by only taking one the other
argument says there's a predictor who's
always right about the future who says
that there's a future in which I get a
million dollars by taking only box B and
a future in which I get only a thousand
dollars by taking both boxes okay so a
this is the stuff this becomes a raging
debate in philosophy circles you can
actually you know if you go up to
professional philosopher and say are you
a one boxer or a two boxer they will
know what you mean you're talking
referring to Newcomb is a paradox here
should you take the one box or should
you take both and I am a one boxer I
think that you should just take box B
and get the million dollars if you
really really really really really
believe that the predictor is always
accurate and the reason why is because I
believe in the block universe I believe
that basically the way you should think
about it is this there is something that
happens in the universe and we're
ignoring again classical classical
versus quantum mechanics multiple
realities anything like that
okay let's imagine we also somehow knew
that the universe is deterministic
basically in my view what is going on
here is there's two possible histories
of the universe one in which you take
both boxes and box B is empty the other
one of which you take only one box and
box B is full of a million dollars okay
and what the predictor is doing is
telling you that those that the real
world which is unique and determined is
one of those two futures you can imagine
a different future in which you took
both boxes and box B had a million
dollars in it but the predictor is
telling you that the real world is not
that that's the information the
predictor is given to you so if that's
what's going on and you're choosing
between two possible futures you don't
know which one you're in but you're
given the ability to choose make one
actually come true now you can believe
the reason why I think this is an
interesting way to think about freewill
is you can say to yourself well you know
I'm made of atoms my atoms obey the laws
of physics they're gonna choose one
thing or another okay so which universe
I'm in is actually secretly already
determined even though I don't know it
fine but that is completely irrelevant
to the fact that you need to make a
choice right now you need to choose one
box or both okay you can sit there and
say well it's determined which one I
will choose fine but choose okay you
don't know which one you are in for all
intents and purposes in the real world
you are faced with not exactly this kind
of problem but you are faced with
choices to make based on the fact that
you don't know what the determined block
future of the universe actually is and
the way to think about that is I'm
ignorant about the future but I can make
certain choices that make certain
futures come true rather than others in
my view in Newcomb's paradox you can
make the universe come true you can
locate yourself in the universe where
you make a million dollars by choosing
to pick box B rather than both boxes
there are people who disagree okay so
there are people who don't quite believe
me about this so be it that's why
philosophy is an interesting thing
usually I think that you know these
puzzles typically are paradoxical
because they're slightly ill-posed like
in this case
it's not ever completely filled in how
the predictor gets their information
about the future like are they really
Laplace this demon or do they just have
recognition or whatever it is are they
creating the future somehow
but given the setup of the problem I
think taking one box is clearly the
right thing to do it's a nice way to
reconcile if it already fits in I I
personally came with Pandu club's
paradox long after my views on the block
universe and compatibilist freewill had
already developed but anyway it's a it's
sort of the future version of the time
travel paradox right the time travel
paradox is I go to the past and I'm
seemingly limited in what can possibly
happen Newcomb's paradox is sort of
taking a piece of information from the
future and bringing it into you right
now it gives you an equally paradoxical
situation that's why thinking about time
is a lot of fun